working with dick smith was from a
child's point of view
at first very frightening
and then as i got to know the person and
to realize
how lucky and amazing an experience it
was to have worked with somebody who
started prosthetic makeup
and has been so instrumental in the
films that we make today
come on the exorcist little big man all
that stuff
so i'm personally not that it's a
competition
but i'm i'm on team dick smith the 70s
for me
is it's one of the greatest errors in
cinema i mean people uh
the filmmakers at the time and the
students at the time seemed very
interested in people
and and real people and real people's
stories and you know i'm always hungry
to get back to that
that's classic cinema those are the kind
of things that people still be watching
a hundred years from now
so anyone that does work on those kind
of films it's it's there's a bit of
immortality in it you know what i mean
yeah i would i always think exorcist
right the game just because
just because it's so brutal and that has
seared my brain
oh are you kidding me i was terrified
and i remember it yeah and i saw all the
uncut scenes
when she's going down the stairs like a
like a spider
man that and that 360. it changed the
whole life
it was innovative well you remember
during that time so many people were
like getting scared out of their wits i
mean people had to go
to to the hospitals to insinus
it was like crazy and my most favorite
were his stories and our shared love for
animals
and he had a pet squirrel and he would
share all these amazing stories
he's a beautiful man he's the godfather
of of of makeup and all the people that
i've worked with
um uh who have
you know all the sort of special makeups
that i've had
uh those people have i've been inspired
by
or have worked with with dick what he
did in the exorcist is is phenomenal
and what happens after that it seems he
sort of was a pioneer
for that kind of makeup and that kind of
uh you know technical sort of aspect of
of making you know amazing images true